at the end of birth usually i'm a
screamer and so
i
really use my voice during the whole
birth process a lot of toning a lot of
moaning
this time i was way more
aware of my breath
um and of the strength of my voice the
other times i just wasn't
diving into that practice but this time
i was so i was aware of that control
that i could have
um with my breath and so towards the end
you know it's you know you're just like
how much longer guys anybody can anybody
help me or tell me when this is gonna be
over and so it was at that point it was
just like in this like open squat with
like my leg open and kind of just like
up
and so there was room for the baby to
plop out and um i started screaming
just like
and what it was doing was taking me out
of my body and into my head again and so
aubry always got the right thing to say
um she said
stop screaming
why don't you just stop screaming
and just be quiet
something around there i don't know if
that was the exact words but it had that
that feeling just like wow let's try
something else because she also knows
that that's what i usually do at the end
she said the baby's coming
at any
second jordan relax you know and you
know at this point i'm like in primal
you know i'm covered in oh my gosh sweat
and
nervousness and excitement
fear all of it you know that you
experience at the end and she says this
to me
to be quiet and i'm just like
let's try you know why not
and so i remember just taking that
breath
and i put my hand down down towards my
yoni and i just breathe
[Music]
that was my friend jordan who recently
gave birth to her fourth baby in the
comfort of her own home while living in
tanzania with her family we came
together today for her to share her
story of her most recent birth and also
to revel in the evolution she's had from
her other births as well
her birth stories are both hilarious and
beautiful chaotic yet calming and also
empowering we found many similarities in
our own lives not just from the
beautiful mess of motherhood and
homeschooling and raising a big family
but also from the insights we've gained
over the course of our different births
we share what has helped us have the
most empowering birth experiences what
hasn't helped and everything in between
you can find jordan on instagram at
phoenix.wild which i'll link in the show
notes and description box for you guys
so you can keep up with her life journey
with her family travels homeschooling
and motherhood she's coming out with a
homeschooling course actually soon so
stay tuned for that and she also just
launched an online marketplace to be
able to find natural mother and baby
products all in one beautiful place
which i'll link for you as well below
all right buckle up for some birth
stories i laughed a lot in this episode
i probably
loved it so much because i find so much
joy talking about birth so i hope you
enjoy it too let's get into it all right
jordan how are you it is so good to talk
to you and finally speak face to face
i agree i'm so well so excited
i'm just so excited so excited to talk
to you
totally we have been online friends
for a while and so it's nice to just
connect and we have so much in common i
feel like especially being in the same
phase of life
of motherhood you just had your fourth
baby and i feel like there's so much
connection there to laugh about with the
chaos of motherhood and
homeschooling as well so
yeah and you're in tas uh tanzania
yes yes
what brought you to tanzania
a call honestly we were just in this
travel flow
and we're content where we were we were
traveling in mexico
and yeah just consent and we just felt a
call that we needed to come and see what
it was like here we intended to move
relocate maybe
but really just to come and experience
africa because this is like
a big dream of ours just to come and set
foot on this piece of earth and so
yeah we heeded the call
flew out here december 21st
2020
auspicious time to be even doing this
anyways you know
and yeah
it's been magical
and yeah what has it been like living
there and where did you come from like
where were you guys born and raised
because that is so fascinating to me
okay so i was born in tallahassee and
tom was born in pittsburgh
and we both met in atlanta
and we had our first child there nakomi
and then
we were in a concrete jungle we're like
hold up this is not the life for us we
packed up and moved to kauai hawaii
and
had two daughters there
honestly would still be there if it
wasn't so different i'm sure you can
attest to how different maui has become
since everything um
and yeah we just felt like we needed to
just move on
kauai hawaii in general just feels like
home or one of our homes so we know
we'll return one day
um but yeah we were in mexico
then we were traveling a little bit in
panama and then we got here
and that is so cool
man
just saying all of that it's like just
such this big breath of adventure and
memories
totally and and yeah like what is it
like in tanzania what's life like there
life is very
slow like pole pole that's what they say
here slow slow it's very meditative
everyone has their work everyone does
their thing
the people here are very
chill happy
very comfortable i would say that very
comfortable
family unit is very strong
um lots of children
a lot of independents as well seeing
that
it's just a lot of differences to
observe living in a country that's
completely
different than what you grew up in um
and so yeah
seeing a lot of reflections a lot of
lessons a lot of difficult things to see
you know
a lot of things that we assumed about
africa in general that have been
debunked and
new things that we're discovering that
would be
great to learn from continuously and
share in platforms like this
um things that you know you may not know
about africa that we would have never
known until we got here so totally so
what's something that you think needs to
be shared that like a lot of people
don't know
um
[Music]
i think that
um there's this need on both ends to
come somehow like this the grass is
greener on the other side
so for black americans
in america it feels like we're missing
something from being
in africa and for africans here
they feel like you know in a way that
they're missing out or that it's just
like this we thinks were
a world of differences from each other
you know that we're so different
um and coming together face to face with
you know reflections of yourself it's
like wow we're really
we're not so different but
it does make it difficult because not
everybody has these realizations you
know people who think that we're
different they think that we're
different they treat us differently
and assume that we're going to be a
certain way when we come and i'm sure
the same happens when they come to
america you know
we assume certain things about africans
and this is not even just for black
americans just americans in general
people in general how we perceive those
who live in africa versus the western
world but
um there's a lot of them wanting to be
like what they think they're supposed to
be which is us you know this western
lifestyle this
you know
all the stigmas that comes with it right
the consumerism the being on the phones
like it's it's it's interesting to see
how much that's revered
even with religion you know
it's really a lot of things are outside
of themselves i definitely came here and
thought i was going to have a way more
indigenous experience really tapped into
like ancestral
lifestyle but there's actually
a lot of people here who are just trying
to be western and you know importing a
lot of things
um and of course i'm having my own
experience here in tanzania
this is the only country that i visited
so
my experience is true for what i've had
here in this country i can't say for
anywhere else um
totally because it's going to be so
different wherever you go
do you plan to go to other countries and
other areas
i think so one day um
yeah we're just like again listening to
the call we're getting the call to go
return back to mexico
and um
hopefully gra actually ground in because
we wanted to do that here but the fl it
just
wasn't in alignment and so
going to
mexico doesn't mean that we'll never
come back here
or that right you know um because i
still want to visit ethiopia
in egypt i've been like to the airport
at ethiopia and it was amazing and so i
definitely want to go there
um kenya ghana i mean there's there's so
much to see and so we'll definitely be
back for sure
that's amazing and the type of life
experience that you're giving your kids
while homeschooling is so special
i think that the traveler an adventurous
mindset is really beautiful especially
while you're homeschooling they get to
learn so much with all the different
cultures and
life experiences through different ways
of life
agreed
i'm so happy for them like they're
they called in the right experience for
them as i know not not everybody gets to
have this experience and they're so it's
such a special time for them especially
just
them being siblings and being able to do
this together you know it's not like i
just have one child
there's four of them now
and yes
i can relate all together yeah oh four
outnumbered is a a trivial thing to say
at this point this is just so many
children
it's
it is safe to say that is true andrew
and i will all like very often look at
each other from across the room and
we're just like
what what's happening
or at night when they're all sleeping
just like what
exploded out of me there's so many
getting names mixed up who are you you
which one are you just come here
finally getting like a deep breath like
a like a just a a heave of like sighing
out like oh okay
the day's over
but it's like this beautiful mess and
chaos and i love with the homeschooling
life that they get to all do it together
and grow from each other and it's just
so beautiful it's like chaotic and
hilarious and
just incredibly loving all at the same
time i agree i agree
so how has the homeschooling been like
with all your travels and
now just having your fourth baby
congratulations by the way i'm so happy
for you and we're definitely gonna get
into that i can't like that's gonna be
the bulk of what we talk about oh yeah
i'm excited how has the homeschooling
been where you're living
yeah so i'm i'm actually grateful that
they're of the age like preschool age
where
it doesn't really alert people if
they're not in school with that being
said homeschooling is illegal here i
don't know what that means things like
that i don't know
i just feel like they don't apply to me
i'm like okay i'm still gonna do it
anyways you know i'll figure it out but
thanks for telling me
but you know
so
people view it they're just like in
shock and all you know at this point
they're just like oh
at home why you know they're schools
you know
it's kind of like on that and also for
like birthing even home birth they're
the same way like why are you gonna do
it at home there's hospitals you know
it's not even really this judgment thing
it's just like for what reason would you
do that when things are set up and so um
they actually went to school for one
full week
because i had actually started the
homeschool flow
and i was feeling overwhelmed i was like
i felt like i was not managing it
properly and that some someone else
could do it better honestly i had that
experience
um and it was really my first try which
is like you know um
just a part of the learning lesson i
guess and so we asked them you know they
also equally agreed right because we're
just not getting along homeschooling
trying to you know whatever what wasn't
working wasn't working and i think we
needed to have
the experience at school to remind us of
why we wanted to do it at school at home
and so they did school they had wake up
early it was like an hour away drive
and i just started feeling like honestly
the feelings of like jealousy like
oh so you guys just get to go to school
and do crafts with some other lady like
i can do this with you you know i just
felt like i was missing out
on all of these amazing things that i
just even naturally love to do myself
you know and so it's just like
you know kind of in that way and
um
kind of the the
the way that they do schooling here is
also it's not like ancestral it's very
like
it's like british curriculum it's like
it's weird because it's like you know i
assumed that maybe some african
lifestyle would be taught but it wasn't
and with
um them being there just a week we
picked that up
and they by the by the end of the week
which is like not into it and so we just
found a way to get out of the school i
mean we enrolled them got the uniforms
it was this whole thing and
uh we're like no this is why we want
them to be home
and we want to all be together and you
know to this day
just asking them or if people ask their
you know we want to be home with mom
like no i don't want to go to school you
know and so for however long that
that continues i'm in support of it and
um
yeah but i'm definitely grateful that
they're preschool age and not like
middle schoolers or anything so
right yeah and part of the reason why
you might have even moved
where you are now is because you're
looking for kind of like the true
original cultural experience and you're
like wait i could just send my kids for
the westernized type of schooling
experience if i was back home so why am
i doing that here
right yeah
and
i think now that you've added a fourth
to your tribe to your group like it just
adds a whole other level of just
intensity with homeschooling and do you
get much help from
your partner antoine like what is the
flow like with your family
yeah so here it's it's all about the
village right that's that that's you
know some things that are embedded that
i don't think will ever wash away just
that strong family unit um and so we
have what's called a dada in our home
it literally translates to sister so i
have a sister in the home who just
i wouldn't even call her a nanny just an
extension of the family someone who
supports
the mother and the flow that you know i
do
throughout the house so once um i had my
fourth
um i had my my dada here supporting the
whole family flow so supporting even
antoine so that ants one can support me
because you know there's certain things
that he can't do but that a woman can
there's certain ways that she you know
brings my postpartum tea and my meals
that you know not that ants one can't
but he gets to do other things um like
support me getting a shower and doing
all the other posts there's so much to
do postpartum especially with three
toddlers running around
you know
yeah and they're you know acclimating to
the new energies as well
um and so
yeah i'm grateful to have been here for
postpartum because we definitely
um
had help in some ways from my other
postpartum but it still was like
it was just different you know to have a
babysitter or nanny in the western world
is
very expensive number one it's not
affordable it's like a you've got to
take a second job just to support the
support in your home you know
and um
although we do have a big family you
know where they're all like in atlanta
and in the south and so
antoine is one of ten like they i
technically should never have to i know
yeah i technically
should never have to worry about
you know extension of ourselves village
wise you know but living in hawaii is
just it's far you know
um not to say nobody could come we
uh we'll just say that for a family
who's watching um
but it is far and
yeah so we just
flowed with what we had during those
postpartum but here i would say
this is the longest i've been able to
like rest in bed
um due to the extra village support so
that is beautiful because a lot of times
you might assume that the more kids you
have the harder it is to rest and the
less likely you're going to be able to
rest but i've also found that the more
children i have the more value i've
placed upon
resting and being willing to reach out
for support and welcome support so that
i can
heal the quickest and just like
rejuvenate myself while i bond with the
baby so that's so great i'm so happy
that you've been able to get that
me too very grateful all right so i
would just love to start talking about
your birth i would love to hear your
first story what your other bursts were
like and compared to this one have you
found any kind of extra transformative
or just revelations through this birth
and yeah let's just talk about it i
could talk about birds for ages honestly
it's just probably out of all the topics
that i'm excited about
this one is like at the top like i could
just go on and on and on and listen to
stories and talk about them and there's
just so much to say so i agree yeah
let's get into it tell me about your
birth
oh man
this is the tale
a tale that i won't soon forget i'll
just say that
it's definitely
danced this way into a story that i
could have never dreamed up
honestly
and that's how birth is right the
unexpected truly happens
outside of anything we could have
planned
or have expected
um and i feel like all of my births were
definitely that way in a big way
when we had this vision
it didn't go the way we envisioned it
and it turned out amazing nevertheless
the baby came right that's the goal for
the baby to come out so
babies came out and we're healthy and
amazing um
and i think just going into it the
number one thing that was the difference
about this fourth birth is that i didn't
anticipate
any kind of story
i didn't dream up
my perfect birth
i just listened
and i just
flowed into
what messages i was getting
from the baby from the pregnancies
and early on
um
that was a lot of the lessons that i
learned with that pregnancy just silence
gathering myself within
and finding the resilience
that it takes to birth
which is just
there lying dormant until birth happens
honestly you know no matter how much you
prepare for birth
you know
you know it's it's so much
deeper and beyond
um what we're set up
to do and prepare
um
and so i just you know the fourth you
know at this point it's like listen i i
i've done this i've done this you know i
don't have anything to fear
fear is not
it doesn't have anything to do with
birth you know pain also like whatever
you know that's not what i'm focusing on
trying to escape it or trying to manage
it you know because it's not pain
it is
intensity
it's a drive to the end so of course
there's sensations that are strong
but it's it really is and it's not about
like finding this
this solitude and meditation or whatever
but it's just like
working hard and having the courage to
do hard work
and to
get what's being promised to you this
whole nine months which is a baby
that's what's supposed to happen
so running from it or fearing it or
trying to like
cope is just gonna take you out of it
it's too much in your mind and so i had
that going into this fourth
this fourth birth
um
and towards the end number one i i this
was like more of like a free birth
experience for me
in terms of me looking outside of myself
right for like checkups or like
um going to a hospital or
doing all these kind of checks and
balances which i definitely like i had a
pregnancy test i did the early
ultrasound
um
but after that i just like i don't like
i don't see the point of going to
um a midwife to tell me things that i
already know i just wanted to listen i
just really just wanted to be left alone
and i feel like i said that a lot during
my pregnancy like leave me alone just
leave me alone that was like my mantra a
lot like nobody touched me just let me
like it was just you know and then as
you get towards the end it's like you
know just please nobody make eye contact
with me just like i just any day i'm
gonna give birth i actually was having
this two months
time where i thought i was gonna give
birth any day i just woke up and i
thought i was gonna give birth that day
so for two months i'm in this this phase
of craziness honestly and
um
once it actually was getting closer
maybe like in january
um i kind of started having this feeling
that i was going to give birth alone
and
um i feel like i probably
was
projecting that onto antoine a lot just
like because he was he was very busy at
this time with just work and us just
just doing a lot of stuff he was just in
his flow and like because i thought i
was gonna give birth every day
him going to the grocery store was just
an immediate concern for me like when
are you gonna be back don't be gone long
i don't want to have this baby by myself
but at a certain point i was like the
boy cried wolf at the end of the day
because for two months you know and so
um
he happens to need to go to zanzibar
um this island that's maybe like an hour
flight away not technically like far
away
um but
at this point of the game i was
going to be giving birth the next maybe
three days from when he left
um
but obviously i didn't know that
and
for the last time i just decided that i
wasn't gonna pester him i wasn't gonna
say you better be back you better not be
gone long because i'm gonna have this
baby i was like you know what i'm not
gonna say that
because this baby is clearly coming
whenever
he or she wants and so whatever and so i
released him to go
and um he's there playing music and
doing his thing
and you know i was at home with the dada
with the kids
and i just start this manic cleaning you
know but again like i felt like i was
doing that a lot anyways i was just
shedding a lot i was just
doing a lot of that already and so
we went to the beach we were doing
homeschooling um the day before i gave
birth i was in the ocean the tide was so
low like
crawling low and so i'm just crawling in
the ocean the ocean was super hot also
because the tide was so low i don't know
it was very it was a very interesting
time in the sea i've
swam in many oceans and i've never
experienced the ocean like that very
flat very calm and hot i felt like it
was a hot tub
and that's when my sensations i would
say
began
and they felt ecstatic honestly they
felt amazing because i was excited and
welcoming of it i wasn't running from it
or looking
for someone to be available to help me
give birth i just wasn't thinking about
that because i hadn't prepared myself to
do that for nine months and so i was
just
enjoying it
and
having fun
eating a lot um
and i just got back and i was just so
relaxed
and um
was on the phone with antoine he was
actually supposed to come back that day
but ended up just being like you know
the flights are just like super late
i'll just be back in the morning and so
okay cool fine whatever i'm releasing
everything
and so
um this baby also was the heaviest the
heaviest pregnancy that i experienced as
well and so
um i went to bed super early just laying
about just just so pregnant
and i went to bed that night
and
was just starting to have different
sensations
went to the bathroom
wiped had that mucus plug it's like all
right
it's time it's game time it's time you
know
and
i don't think initially the fact that
antoine wasn't there
immediately crossed my mind i think i
just
i just missed him in that moment missed
having that experience with him like
for him to like see like okay i'm not
joking like you can
smell and feel and see and all that like
with me and so
um
the first part of the birth i did have
to go through a release of that again um
a few weeks prior
um our daughter uh the nanny who who
stayed she was living with us at the
time
she woke up one morning and was like
i had a dream
that you gave birth on the floor and you
were holding onto the bed and antoine
wasn't here
and i was like
okay
um
because i also was having
this feeling that i just it wasn't gonna
go
with that plan something that we always
expect
you know for us just to be doing the
birth dance together
and um
you know i i just took it in i was like
okay
interesting
um my midwife on kauai who helped me um
with the births of my two daughters
in hawaii she also had a dream that
antoine wasn't going to be there
wow once my sensations were
intensifying i actually called
um my um midwife aubry aubry jones she's
amazing i called her and um yeah she
told me the dream as soon as i got on
the phone was like wow i had this vision
that he wasn't going to be there oh i'm
getting chills
wow that is insane
yeah and so i call antoine i'm on the
phone with him you know the whole time
obviously
and i'm i'm you know going through all
these emotions with them you know like
i'm angry i'm like excited that the you
know the birth is happening i'm like
where are you why are you here you know
having those moments
and you know him on that end just
imagining the turmoil and
the panic that he felt you know he was
really good about being chill but i know
he was just like oh my gosh because he
knows what i sound like when i'm going
i'm going and this labor was fast ellen
it was quick it was so quick that i
felt myself trying to hold her in
you know trying to not go there because
if he was there oh i would have gone
quick quickly it would have just
sneezed out like i anticipated you know
right and
just
i know it's happening you know but i was
i was definitely holding and waiting
um because his flight was early there
was the possibility that he could have
gotten there
to see the baby um emerge and all of
that um but i had to
um release that and it was definitely
that was that work of that birth and so
i was having strong sensations in bed i
was holding on to nakomi in my oldest
son's hand from through most of a lot of
the intense surges until i just could
not stand being in the bed anymore and i
got up was in the bathroom i called um
alice up
and i was like i you know this is this
is it and i told her to go to sleep get
some rest and i was like but if i call
you
that means i need you to come and i just
need you to be with me um so make sure
your phone is on um because i was
upstairs and she was downstairs and so
alice is the doctor is the dada yes
yes alice is a dada yep and so she went
back to sleep and i was kind of just
dancing through it myself again just
squeezing nakomi's hand through surges
and it just got to a point where i just
like i said i couldn't lay down and so i
called alice i kept calling her i was
betting i was like okay i can't walk i
can't go downstairs and get her i need
her to be here and so i go to this top
of the stairs and i'm like alice
just like get up here
and so i went back in the bathroom and i
was even i've been really sad i was like
maybe she's just gonna sleep and i'm
just gonna really do this myself i was
like whatever whatever and so i have
aubry on the phone and she's
um she's amazing at supporting me in
birth because she's not like
babying me or like oh go get your oils
or do this position or she's like okay
you know what you need to do
make sure you're breathing correctly
um you know she just holds space and
that's what i need
for me someone doing that pacifying
thing just really takes me out of what i
need to get accomplished you know and so
she tells me everything that i need to
hear and even i started
crying at one point i was just like yes
what's that here what is happening and
she was like listen you he can't help
you with anything anyways you know like
he can't do anything this is you you
know and
you know i feel like she always says
something to hurt my feelings a little
bit during birth and that would hurt my
feelings i was like
but it pushed me because it was like
okay like get out of your head just talk
to the baby let's like dance and get
this baby out and it sounds like that's
exactly what you needed to hear
yes
and i totally had that too in my certain
verse where like my midwife would say
something and i'm like ah that's not
what i wanted to hear but then later on
like
exactly like i had a time where i would
ask my midwife like is it almost time
like is this is almost over it's taking
forever and she's like you're one
contraction closer to your birth i'm
like ah shut up
that's not what i wanted to hear
that
and now a few words from our sponsor who
helps make this show possible
we're brought to you today by buffy you
guys i'm telling you every time a friend
or guest lays down in these sheets and
comforter they are blown away by how
soft and cozy it is and i can say
without a doubt that buffy enhances my
sleep so in addition to that what's so
great about buffy is that they are
dedicated to making a positive impact on
not only our sleep but also the
environment using only renewable and
recycled materials which makes them as
soft on the planet as they are on your
bed their debut product the cloud
comforter is covered in super soft
eucalyptus fabric and filled with fluffy
fiber made from 100 recycled bottles
this comforter has over 18 thousand five
star reviews it keeps you at the perfect
temperature so you feel cozy without
overheating and it is by far my favorite
comforter i've ever slept with it's
hypoallergenic and machine washable
thanks to an innovative stitching batter
that keeps its fluffy fill in place plus
its high thread count shuts out dust
mold and mites for a healthier sleep
environment the best part for me though
is that the average down comforter harms
12 geese but buffy's comforter is made
cruelty free it feels even softer than
down while keeping approximately 50
bottles out of landfills and oceans so
use my code ellen for twenty dollars off
orders over eighty dollars you can try a
comforter in your own bed for free if
you don't love it return it at no cost
and i feel like that's how we're taught
to manage pain sometimes you know to
kind of baby our way out of it or just
you know
find that nurturing when really we have
the strength to heal and to
move through these bodily sensations on
our own
and
um it's definitely hard lessons to learn
when you're in the thick of it
but like you said it's what we needed to
push through
um and so yeah alice was there
really as my physical anchor because she
was honestly i feel speechless because
she's tanzania and she's in this culture
where you know you go to the hospital
yeah she's aware that we can give birth
and i told her many weeks
prior like hey like i'm doing this at
home
you know you're probably gonna be here
so she was she was ready she was in awe
and she was even researched herself
because i told her we were going to do a
lotus birth and all these new things to
her and so i think she was just really
excited to see if i was going to carry
this out you know and so she was just
there physically i was holding on to her
as i would have done if antoine was
there
you know the difference with antoine is
he's obviously very soothing and he's
very protective so i feel very safe in
that way
but she really held space
in the way that i would have held on to
antoine physically and you know just to
kind of beat up in there you know hold
me up get this for me do this and she
just silently was there and oh my god it
was amazing it was the perfect balance
that i needed to just be in the zone and
do my thing and so within a few short
hours you know i'm on the phone my last
conversation i have with antoine and i
think he really knew the baby was gonna
come and he was not gonna be there um
that there was a potential for it um he
was getting off the plane catching a
boat a boater which is a moto motorcycle
so this guy like can you just imagine
this guy who has a baby on the way
with his locks flailing in the wind on a
motorcycle and he's like get
to
my house
immediately and he said that the guy he
he really like
like swerved through tanzania to get him
here
and
man i'm like
holding on to the back of the bed frame
slipping and sliding on the bed we had
like alice didn't really know how to set
the bed up for a home birth because you
know like you can put the the shower
mat under the
the bed fully made so you can just rip
it off but she just put the shower mat
on the bed and so like my water bursts
and i'm like holding on to her we're
covered in water
okay wait wait wait oh my god pause
pause anyone anyone who's listening
who's like what the heck is she talking
about um either if you haven't had um a
baby yet or maybe you haven't had a home
birth yet a lot of times midwives will
say let's put a shower curtain
underneath your bed sheet to protect
your mattress but that way you get to be
on top of your bed sheet i'm like dying
right now that way you get to be on top
of your bed sheet so um that you can be
comfortable still
but dada put the sheet on top of the bed
or to put the curtain on top of the bed
sheet which is like the slippery shower
curtain slippery so you're like sliding
on the bed while you're in flavor
it was so crazy
and i couldn't get my like grounding
because i like to be like in a deep
squat and i couldn't
and so
i feel like uh some kind of like nerve
was being pinched with the pressure of
the baby coming down
in addition to me slipping and sliding
so that part was very aggravating me
aggravating for me during that part
because
if i just could have stomped my leg in a
certain way then i could have just
pushed her out way earlier probably um
but i kind of was doing that dance for a
while and then the midwife that we were
um
in connection with just for paperwork
stuff and just uh just to have
she showed up randomly
and her perfume that she was wearing
smelled terrible
like this is when i'm slipping and
sliding like i'm about to like i think
30 minutes later she was born and so she
comes in and she like touches my back
you know she's just you know
you know she's amazing she's a wonderful
person but she needed to get away from
me at that point and so she like touches
my back and i like throw her hand off
and i'm like get out
and she's like oh should we check the
baby get out
and so that happens
and um alice is on the phone with
antoine he's almost there he's on the
phone with me
and
um
at the end of birth usually i'm a
screamer and so
i i
really use my voice during the whole
birth process a lot of toning a lot of
moaning
this time i was way more
aware of my breath
and of the strength of my voice the
other times i just wasn't
diving into that practice but this time
i was so i was aware of that control
that i could have
um with my breath and so towards the end
you know it's you know you're just like
how much longer guys anybody can anybody
help me or tell me when this is going to
be over and so it was at that point
the pressure was coming i don't
experience the ring of fire necessarily
but i just feel like a full full full
body intensity that's just like ah
just like you know
um and usually at this point i'm holding
on bearing down right antoine
is usually his neck is about to break at
this point
my birth my two daughters the same way
just kind of holding onto his neck and
bearing down and so i was trying to
mimic that but
that wasn't
happening and so i was just like in this
like open squat with like my leg open
and kind of just like up and so there
was room for the baby to plop out
and um
i started screaming just like
and what it was doing was taking me out
of my body and into my head again and so
aubry always got the right thing to say
um she said stop screaming
why don't you just stop screaming
and just be quiet
something around there i don't know if
that was the exact words but it had that
that feeling just like wow let's try
something else because she also knows
that that's what i usually do at the end
she said the baby's coming
at any
second jordan relax you know and
you know at this point i'm like in
primal you know i'm covered in oh my
gosh
sweat and
nervousness and excitement
fear all of it you know that you
experience at the end and she says this
to me
to be quiet and i'm just like
let's try you know why not
and so i remember just taking that
breath
and i put my hand down down towards my
yoni and i just breathed
and i could
feel the communication that i was having
with her
let's go are you ready i'm i'm waiting
to assist you i'm here as your assistant
this is also your story
and i was able to connect with her in
silence and
i breathed her out
and it was the most peaceful
transition of change in my life that
i've ever experienced i feel like
oftentimes change for me happens and i
have to make like a big fuss about it it
has to be like this dramatic
pull of energy like i don't want to
change you know
and
this birth really changed that for me
just the power of being quiet
silence and breath
and she came out
and it was so quiet
that it kind of alerted
my dada she was like that was the first
time that she panicked the first time
that she was like
she was like
she's supposed to be crying she's
supposed to be crying actually we didn't
know if she was this year here at that
point but she was like maybe supposed to
be crying and she wasn't crying she
plopped out and i held her and she just
kind of gave out this little squeak like
this little
i'm here like
you know and it was just so cute
covered in vernix
and i got to like just like be in that
space that i never was there also for
the other birds because i was so
exhausted from screaming right and just
get out get out you know just that that
release i always had that kind of
experience but this time it was like
inward it was here and i was able to
to hold that moment and i i'll never
ever forget that and then of course the
chaos happens
dada goes alice goes against the kids
they're downstairs and also we were
anticipating a boy
um nakomi really just wanted a brother
and we have two girls so you know we
kind of were like oh maybe we'll have a
boy you know more than we were like
anticipating a girl obviously we were so
excited for either but having a girl was
like i said the whole pregnancy if i
have a girl i should laugh because i
think it would be so funny um and so
that's exactly what happened she came
out i checked
and i was like oh my god like it's a
girl like this is so hilarious this is
this birth story is so funny it's so
funny and so the kids come running up uh
and nakomi immediately was like
i'm like it's a sister's a little sister
immediately i tell him and nicole is
downstairs watching tv and he's like
it's a girl and he goes back downstairs
he's very disappointed
he loves her now he came back up
eventually but i think he was just kind
of like he was kind of with me through
the whole birth this is his also his
third birth you know so he's like all
right another sister
so he goes back down and we're just
loving up on her and antoine comes in 20
minutes later 20 minutes after she
emerged in the crazy gosh that is a
crazy story
he literally just missed it and so also
we know that that's also the way the
baby wanted to be born for whatever
reason i needed to have that experience
um and i wasn't alone you know he was
there he was definitely there and he
just walked in and we just both were
just like
laughing i'm sure just laughing you know
it's just like so light-hearted
you know there's no need to be like
you you know like whatever you know the
baby's here we've been waiting for this
baby and so
you take this too
and then it just goes and so the rest is
history here we are
oh my gosh that is an amazing birth
story it's hilarious for one and i love
i love when you're talking about how
this birth you really
once the um you were told like kind of
brought to your attention like hey
center yourself even just stop screaming
that's astounding to me i've never heard
anyone just like tell a birthing mother
stop screaming like i feel like i'd be
like what the heck are you trying to
tell me to stop screaming i know i love
it in a way that was empowering though
so i think that's right the difference
with her voice yeah for sure right the
way you say it and you you took that in
an empowering way and were able to
center yourself
and then
just be really present with your body
and your mind and your heart like
because i really felt like that with my
fourth birth as well i felt
so in control and then not like
in control of everything but more just
like in control of my mind and my
presence and
with the other ones i was more likely to
just be like
outer body experience it's happening to
me
with the while i'm giving like the baby
is like ascending and like coming out
but with this fourth one it was more
like
i have the power to decide how i'm going
to
use my voice with this one and i didn't
feel that way with the other ones isn't
that interesting it is
magic of four is something
something about that i think it's like
just like you said you know i've done
this before there's not fear involved i
know that my body can do this i was made
for this
and i feel just empowered and so
i definitely see similarities there i
haven't had an experience like yours
with all those hilarious circumstances
but i think it's amazing and so
so special
and my eldest is the same way like he's
seen not the same way in his reactions
to birth but
like he's seen all of his siblings be
born and it's like just so cool and like
i tell him i'm like you know there's a
lot of adults who have never even seen
one baby be born and you've seen three
babies oh yeah yeah that's so and to be
the the men that they'll be growing into
to have had these experiences wow i
totally agree i think about that often
i'm like as they grow older and
um like interact with women in their
lives like how empowering that is for
them the way that they'll be able to
look at women and know what they can do
and obviously that doesn't mean that's
like what only thing we do just to
clarify but just but it's important
it's an important thing that our body
does and just like
just being very like in awe of
what we what we do what we can do
you know
yeah it's it we're definitely creating a
new kind of man
they're different you know
right and how to support it's like
learning how to support women
through
like the incredible it's like basically
mystical and magical when you really
think about it like to just be able to
see like look here's what you can do i'm
here to support you and be there for you
and i'm picturing your partner just like
in this frenzy trying to get home to his
wife i can't even imagine like being
like
like you're he's like this man that's
like i gotta get home to my woman and to
my children like she's having she's
having a baby our baby and i'm not there
i'm like that that is like
andrew would be the same way i could
only imagine
we got to get we got to get antoine to
do his his version because
you know
i'm just i'm sure he hasn't really dived
into all of the intricacies that
happened because that that is also a
wild story just to totally yeah even i'm
sure he felt bad you know and the guilt
and we definitely dived into it many
weeks that was our journey together to
just you know
that was an experience you had you know
alongside of me giving birth like wow
you know
um
that definitely opened up new gates for
our relationship as well and you know
and you know with each birth he
definitely has a new respect for me but
i think this one he really was just like
wow i'm proud of you like you really did
that like you really you really he did
it the first three times but you like
wow you know so i've definitely felt
like just beaming in in pride and
happiness that
you know he saw me in that light as well
because
oh
yeah no one wants to go into something
alone
you know feeling a weird way and i
definitely didn't feel that way i felt
supported and held and it was amazing
right and what a like fantastic moment
when he opens the door and his wife has
just given birth to your baby
and is like
wow like look what you just did and it's
like i feel like it's that's such a
special moment like all you can do is
just laugh and be like just so
overwhelmed with joy like that babies
yeah that's so so cool so how did you
this birth compared to your previous
burst what were some pivotal experiences
in the burst you've had before were all
of your burst home births did you have
some hospital bursts
yeah i'd love to hear that kind of
comparison
i think that the crazy funnyness
happened with all three of the other
verses as well just like really just the
strangest things occurred
that were just laughable honestly
um
now of course i think for then it was
like more trauma involved i feel like
that we had to heal from like it's funny
to us now but
back then it was like well that kind of
sucked you know uh but i think that
expectation that control
changes that dynamic also i think that
we healed differently from this birth
because of how we prepared for it um we
didn't prepare in the same way with the
others um
with nakomi my first birth
it was an attempted home birth
um
we were just
mismatched i would say with the midwife
there's a lot of stories with midwives
who kind of
freeze up
when
it gets to a certain point in labor
especially with um first-time mothers
and we had that experience you know
hearing a lot of mothers who've had
similar experiences we know what it
we understand now but during that time
was very painful to have trusted someone
for nine months and for them to
completely flip because of
the system and expectations and fear of
what would happen
instead of just holding space for
us as a wise woman which she totally
could have done um but i understand now
27 hours is a long time it is
completely normal for first birth but
it's a long time and i think everyone
was
exhausted like i said antoine's one of
ten i think six of his siblings were
there in addition to my parents
my brothers
um
the midwife came she brought another
midwife that i never even met i don't
know why she did that
she was there i think there was even
another birth attendant there it was a
full
house party and and that that makes a
lot of sense you know
yeah yes
it's not recommended to do that
no
um i think for anyone listening to who
might be like yeah yeah for anyone who
might be listening and is like well why
not have a bunch of people there and you
know for some women that might be okay
in the case but for a lot of it might
work like i have one of my friends who
recently in the last year gave birth and
she told all of her friends to come over
right as the baby was crowning and she
had like 10 or maybe it was like 5 to 10
of her friends just like watching her
give birth she just got she just has
that personality and that like
that specific birth experience was like
really empowering for her and she really
really enjoyed that um but for a lot of
women especially i think a first time
yeah a first-time birth but really any
birth like i i definitely don't want to
have a crowd of people in my space when
i'm giving birth i try to describe it as
it's kind of like if you're going to the
bathroom do you really want like five
people standing in the doorway like
watching you go to the bathroom is it
you know it's a very comfortable yeah
it's a very it's a very private
primal experience and intimate
experience and with my first birth i
remember my midwife telling me to go
in my room and be alone with my partner
and to be intimate and i'm like what are
you talking about that is the last thing
i want to do right now
i was so just like god is here
yeah
so not on the plane the same plane with
that but then after i gave birth the
second still felt definitely hard no but
then the third time i did a lot of mine
work and a lot of shifting which i have
up on my youtube channel
talking about what i did to prepare for
this third birth because i wanted to do
it differently because my first two were
very long like yours my first birth was
26 hours second birth was like 24 hours
and i was as much as i loved all my home
births i had all beautiful safe home
births i look at the second one and i
was very like a little disappointed in
myself like why wasn't it quicker most
people the second baby goes a lot
quicker and it wasn't for me so then
when i was pregnant with this one
the third one i was like
i'm gonna do it different so i did this
a lot of mind shifting and at that birth
i wanted to be alone and intimate with
my partner and it completely changed the
game for our birth but anyways go back
to what you were saying
about your first birth
yeah um
yes it was a full it was a full-on party
and so obviously like i you know my
stories get hilarious like they get real
crazy um and so it got to the end 27
hours i stopped talking
um
and so everyone freaked out usually at a
certain point in all my births i do go
mute except for the toning or the
screaming or whatever but i don't say
any more words you know i say things in
my head but nobody can hear me you know
i just don't talk and so i did that the
first time and of course i don't even
know that i do that that that's
something i do when i birth you know
that i
go silent so everyone freaked out they
put oxygen on me
um
freaking ants went out like it was a you
know like when the energy of fear begins
it
spreads like wildfire and so there was
fear in the whole house right and even i
was also like well what is going on
needless to say 30 minutes later i gave
birth but it wasn't without
all of this trauma and abuse from the
medical system that i had to deal with
um they called the ambulance
antoine carried me down the stairs
outside to the ambulance oh my god just
even thinking of the story i get into
the ambulance they won't let him sit in
the back with me
he has to sit up in the front
30 minutes i'm giving birth right um the
lady in the back she's like you need to
calm down you're not about to give birth
i've had a lot of kids you have a long
time to go and so just completely rude
to me and i'm like again i'm i'm mute
and so i'm like pulling on her shirt
like i'm about to give birth you know
i'm like what is happening you know and
she's just like not giving me anything
and so they drive slow it's not like an
emergency i've never ever seen an
ambulance just drive like normal they
stopped at every red light it was so
strange
you know and i'm apart from my partner
so we pull up to the ambulance you know
casually hello we're here it's an
emergency
and i get out and they check me and i'm
crowning
he's there and the lady who sat in the
back with me her face just went white
she was so embarrassed they rushed me
into a room
and again the room is filled with people
it's freezing
it's the lights are bright it's just
everything we were trying to avoid right
by having a home birth and so once he
takes off his shirt and stuffs it into
the air vent it was so freezing it was
chaotic and so i'm pushing i'm screaming
nothing's happening
um the guy who's who's
you know there the doctor he's like
totally over it this is like probably
his 99th birth of the day and he's like
all right this girl's going to take a
long time so i get a moment to kind of
gather myself i'm being challenged by
this guy i'm like oh oh you think i'm
not about to give birth and then i
scream
and out he comes and
so we had that experience for the first
birth and that really just put that fire
in us like no matter what we're never
coming back here i get into my room
there's a bag of candy where's my
postpartum meal where is the care
you know we were forced
they were tried to force iv all this
stuff and it just was like so we got out
of there as quick as we could and so
that was that first birth um
and you know in prior times i would say
that it was traumatic but now it's just
like you know it's my initiation it's
what i needed
in order to have
the consecutive births that i had um and
so the two girls obviously we left even
the city went to hawaii they were both
home births
um with aubry um very like
gentle supported but again the stories
just got crazy for for my second
um
we were
um staying
um in this house and i went into labor
and my husband got up and told the
landlady hey she's in labor and the
landlady goes oh you guys need to move
out
you need to be out of here in the next i
think like nine or 24 hours it was like
a weird number too she's like you have
to get out um and we were like what
we just told you we were in labor why
why do we need to leave
um come to find out her father actually
died that morning
coincidentally and she just was going
through whatever i don't know why she
would kick us out i don't think that was
a good idea
but so we're like instantly homeless i'm
packing up i'm like in early labor for
that one
my doula we call her we're like hey can
you i don't know what we're doing but
can you and another lady picks up not
the doula the doula has fallen down the
stairs and has
twisted her ankle or something crazy and
so she can't come to the birth again
someone we've been building with this
whole time like having this expectation
the story and my baby's like no everyone
can get out of the way i don't want to
birth here i don't want her here and so
we go to this wonderful ladies house and
i give birth there she opens her home
um to women who need to give birth and
she opened her home to us i give birth
and then we're homeless right
we're homeless so i go and we go and we
actually live with aubry for a few
months after i give birth and so that's
that story and then that's the whole
kauai hawaii living in a van life and
building up our business and then just
changing in that way and then i i have
um
my third birth and that one was very
like
i feel like that one went most to plan
that one was the most that like just was
like chill like i gave birth i was
supported by my community on hawaii was
brought oranges and fresh meals and it
was amazing in that way
and um maybe that one that one didn't
have too much funniness
i think no that was that was true yeah
that's what i thought the only i guess
the only thing that was different about
that one is um my second daughter she
was born on the 8th of january and um
metta was born on the 7th of january
within a few hours of her older sister's
birthday so they're kind of like twins
in some way as well
exactly two years apart you know so i
guess her emergence that that was funny
um in that sense and they both were
exactly four hours long the labor
i think i did what you did
for your third on my second
i went and had that
intimate quiet time with myself for my
second and that made the labor just
quick yeah
yeah that's definitely something that i
would recommend for anyone who's looking
to have you know an empowering birth
experience to only have the people at
your birth who are going to support you
in ways that you need that's something
that my first midwife had said like to
don't have anybody at your birth that's
there for them this isn't about them
this is about you so you don't need all
these extra family there just because
they feel like grabbing the popcorn and
witnessing a birth like someone should
be at your birth if they're gonna
empower you and be impactful and helpful
for your experience
and that was really helpful advice so
i've always only had like the
people that i wanted at my birth and i
think that was really helpful
um because sometimes you hear these
stories like kind of what you have with
your first birth where there's just too
many people there's just so much
pressure
and outside you know what they're
thinking and it's like oh now there's
fear and there's worry and that really
does affect you internally so like
having the people at your birth who
believe in you who know you can do this
who help empower you and are there
in ways that is helpful for you
is i think really really helpful so what
do you think are some like
practical things for people who are
listening to this and are like look i'm
looking to have
maybe a different experience than they
had in their past birth or maybe it's
their first birth going into it what is
the most helpful
like tools that you've learned to
just have an empowering birth experience
or a transformative birth experience
um i think
that you know words have a lot of power
you know words are spells we're
constantly casting spells with how
how we identify and label things and so
i think a lot of the wording around
birth is very like
confusing you know like pain or
contractions or even the idea of timing
contractions this expectation
for things to go cookie cutter
to just change all of that to fit you
you know for me
sensations feel good you know
for another you know another word may
feel more comforting you know waves you
know
there's
you know many other things you can say
instead of pain and contractions because
those things for me pain and
contractions that makes me think of you
know hospital bursts or what i've seen
on tv and that's not what i want to
experience
unfortunately
the power of words you know is is is is
very
um
important you know and so just shifting
that i think is important that's a tool
that i really use this fourth time um
fear you know
yeah it's just important to to rewrite
the story you know instead of just
planning it just rewrite it the story is
you know birth happens
you know it's physiological it is
something that we can just do you know
so the story has been written for the
way
it's supposed to go so just like reword
and dance with it just make it
lighthearted go into it you know i just
like to laugh about things that are
supposed to be serious not laugh at them
but just laugh with them laugh at a new
perspective and just be open-minded so
um yeah prepare the way that you want to
prepare you know have your room set up
be cozy have your
the things you like to smell and eat but
just like you know like just don't rely
on anything
um outside of yourself and just like
that's how you can maintain that um just
rewrite your own story
yeah i think totally the rewinding
rewinding your story rewriting what you
believe birth is supposed to be and look
like is like
ties in together what you were saying
with like all all the things that you've
seen in your past growing up of what
what you were told birth is supposed to
look like i mean movies to this day i
was just watching a show last night that
was just showing the most
ridiculous version of birth and it's
like this is just
this is just what they show and it's not
to say that that never happens but this
is the only story that is told over and
over again on
television and it's just what we're kind
of like taught from a young age that
like birth is supposed to be
so painful and you're screaming the
whole time and it's panic and it's yeah
um
and that's why the rewriting of your
story and also the mind change is really
helpful because i think
a lot of times too you might be able
because i did like hypno babies
hypnobirthing when i was pregnant with
my first and i remember so it was very
much about like waves and changing the
language and the words
and when i was in labor i remember
saying
this hypno birthing is [ __ ]
so i was like
this is doing
nothing
like i was like no i feel everything
it's so painful no matter how i use say
the words right it's doing nothing
yeah and i remember like it was just
taking a long time and but i remember
telling
my midwife we thought because you know
it's your first time and you feel like
oh this is it like i feel this baby's
about to come and then you call your
midwife or you go to the hospital and
they're like yeah you got a ways to go
and they don't even have to check you
and i'm like how could you know that
like it's happening
and now
it's like you just know i learned over
time that they know because you go you
ship your mind like like your persona
shifts you're in a place in the
beginning where you're like feeling it
but you're present you're looking at
people in the eye you can talk and then
you get to a place where it's like you
literally cannot look at anyone leave me
alone like you can't yeah that's why
it's surprising when you stop talking
that it's surprise that it made people
afraid in your birth because it's very
normal once you get to that like
transition phase where you have to
yes you go to this like place where you
literally cannot look anyone in the eye
and you're so focused
it's animalistic absolutely yep
yes absolutely but so i was my midwife
had come and she's like
i'm gonna i'm gonna go get some coffee
and i was like what like the baby's
coming and she's like you got a ways to
go so i was so disappointed in that and
then i called her back because i was
like this is so hard and she came back
and then
she was telling me to go be intimate
like i said this is my first birth and
when i was i was trying to be alone i
definitely don't want to be intimate
with with my partner but i just went to
go be in like closed dark room with him
and just going through the waves and
stuff and
the hypno birthing lady was on the tape
telling me to relax your birthing
muscles and
the waves and you know and i was like
ugh like i was like this is doing
nothing and then my midwife came in and
she's like ellen ellen she like snapped
me like to got me to like focus because
i'm just so like oh terrible just so
outer body like not
not centered heart sudden she's like
relax and she's like listen to the lady
on the tape and i really didn't want to
but she's like
relax those birthing muscles right there
and she like pointed right here cause i
was trying to relax my arms i was trying
to relax my face and like that's all
good too but i was tight here and when
you tight you're holding in and you're
preventing
or preventing that flow and that
progression and it was when she really
snapped me out of it kind of like with
your fourth birth when you were told to
stop screaming in a very empowering way
she was like that with me she was very
like
listen you got this like slow down relax
right there and she's like oh you're
never gonna progress like it's not gonna
not saying the baby would never come but
she's like this is not gonna go the way
you want it if you don't relax right
there and so then i gave birth like
within an hour after that it was crazy
how it was just like it's a very
yeah and so that's why sometimes the
words are helpful but if your
subconscious
really believes that birth is painful
and long and hard and horrible no matter
if you're saying the words waves or
you know positive language sometimes
it's so deep that you really have to go
and like heal your inner
wounds and your inner traumas around
what you think birth is supposed to look
like and that's what i do in my third
and what it sounds like you did with
your second and it really it really
transforms it yep
and just looking at birth is like it's
it's hard work it's like a physical
act
it's physical that doesn't mean you need
to prepare with yoga or working out but
it's something you have to work with
your body because it's something that
it's moving a human is moving
down
like it's nuts you know i think that we
we hear it but we don't really believe
it you know yeah with that first birth
we're like it's just supposed to happen
birth is just supposed to happen but
it's like but what do you what do you
what do you think was gonna happen
the baby's up he's gotta come down and
out you know um and so welcoming like
yes this is the point this is the point
of this you know
you know it's like you're saying you
know using the bathroom like you're not
gonna be using the bathroom and hold it
in and then be upset because it's not
coming out it doesn't make any sense
release relax it's supposed to come out
let it
absolutely
and something else that i think is
really really helpful just in accordance
with what you're just saying
is going towards the places that you're
afraid to go that you don't want to go
because like you said it's not just
happening to you you're you're doing it
it's easy to be like oh i'm just this
passenger and this is just happening to
me and no like you you are a part of
this and you are doing this and so once
i realized that and realized through
each birth i learned more and more how
much it's not just about relaxing
you know through the whole thing or
relax the muscles find the comfortable
place because that was kind of what i
was told even in all the birthing books
that i read
i really didn't see anyone talking about
the importance of going
to the places that are the most
uncomfortable yes and relaxing there
because like i didn't learn that until
the third and fourth birth where i was
like oh i need to go there in order to
progress so the first ones i was trying
to hide from it i was trying to run away
from it as soon as i felt discomfort and
pain i would just go and get to the most
comfortable position i could get in so
that i didn't feel it but that would
slow the progression down that would
make everything kind of slow down it was
when i got to those places where baby
was like oh i can come down this way
this is this is a position that i can
come down
that you feel it the most but that's
where you have to relax is right there
where you don't want to relax the places
that are you're so afraid to go to
because you've never felt those
sensations before
so that did you feel the same way do you
feel like it's like that as well for you
absolutely
you have to run towards the fights like
i said like it's hard work like i'm
welcoming this
so i'm gonna run towards you i'm not
gonna dance around you even though i
have the tools to fight you and win you
know like no i'm gonna run towards you
and i'm gonna defeat you you know it's
like that kind of mentality like i'm not
gonna like
okay this is intense like you said that
means it's it's okay it's a green light
the baby's like all right let me go like
it's like the babies that they're like
you know
whatever gets a good point then he's
trying to shoot through and then you're
like no i need to relax
yeah and
the baby's like okay you know and that's
when you know
you know it gets delays or you know it's
all this and then
it takes you out of it too i feel like
um it takes you out of that primalness
because you get primal you're like hold
on hold on and then you come out of it
oh i need to relax and that's why i
never
enjoy for people to be around me who
want me to relax and i want people
around me who are going to be like hey
let's let's let's go let's get this done
um because it's easy because it is hard
work it's tiring it's exhausting so when
someone gives you a hand they're like
come on just relax over here of course
you're going to be like thank you you
know yeah
but it's not what you need
right and that's not to say there is
never a time and a place for like
relaxing if you've been going through a
lot of hard work but a lot of times
we're just kind of told the like just
retreat relax that that relaxing your
body without the realization that like
you literally those positions where you
feel it the most that's where you want
to be and that's where you need to relax
the most and that's where it's the
hardest to relax and that's where it's
the most transcendent like it's like
it's so transformative and when i've
seen like multiple friends of mine
give birth now and when you see them go
to those places where they're doing it
it's like this otherworldly but so
empowering thing i just
gives me goosebumps
i can't wait to be at a birth that's
definitely something i can't wait for
oh yeah
totally i see myself like after the kids
are all grown i'm like maybe me and my
best friends will just become midwives
and doulas so we can keep experiencing
birth
because it's special
it is so special it's it's it's magic
that's it's
i know it's beautiful i also find it
really helpful to
um visualize like sexiness do you feel
like that's something in regards to we
were talking about intimacy and stuff
like that
but really the visualization of like
plump
juicy softness because because your mind
is so powerful it connects it's totally
connected to you and your body down
there so like all of that was stuff i
definitely didn't do the first two times
the first two times was much more
subconscious was very like fear-based
and
you know clenching tightening resisting
and then once you're like enveloping
yourself open and stuff like that
i feel like that that is very very
helpful to me
yeah definitely my experience in the
ocean um the day before was like i i i
describe it as like ecstasy like it was
like erotic for me like
just feeling
everything i was feeling it was like
things are gonna happen soon and they're
happening now and like
i can understand why people would think
it would be painful and i also can
understand why people use the water oh
my gosh because i i never like using
water in birth um
still don't i've never used it in birth
but for those early sensations oh my god
it was so wonderful i was just like oh
well i'll just stay here it was just
wonderful and it wasn't even about like
i don't know intimacy but just like
feeling in love with the way my body was
um communicating with me like i just
loved being communicated to so intensely
and to have the ocean just hold me um so
yeah i definitely i never understood how
a birth could be ecstatic you know i was
like okay let's
why are you tapping into that durian but
it's it's very
that's how the baby got here also
everything is it's very it's very
similar in many ways
um being totally giving birth
yeah
whenever i talk about my favorite birth
book called orgasmic birth people are
like what orgasmic what what are you
talking about
why are those two words together
right
but i think it's really helpful for
people who are
who are listening and
being able to hear stories like this
that are like really beautiful and
empowering and soft and just
just ecstatic like you said and that's
that's not to say though that those the
other stories are not beautiful and
important they they are they absolutely
all are and so for anyone who is
listening that maybe has had
some
trauma in past bursts and previous
bursts do you have any advice for women
like you yourself having an experience
that like you said you started to talk
about it and you felt these feelings
just come up from
the way you were treated your first
birth what advice do you have for women
who are listening who have maybe gone
through a harder birth experience and
they're looking for
you know a redemptive
second third or whatever
number birth that is for them
yeah i would just say just just know
that you're you're a part of the change
that's happening you're part of the
rebirth so it's painful for all of us to
even have traumatic experiences at all
in preparation for our daughters to
never experience this
so
i would just say to just have courage
and just know that whatever story is
laid out for you
is is what these next starseeds need in
order for them to just
i mean
for the husbands and wives of these next
generations you know these couples these
people who are going to be procreating
like wow what what grace they get to
enter into this with you know we're
definitely at the tail end of this after
a couple birds able to have this grace
and this
this understanding but they get to have
that
at the beginning from birth right they
get to be in this safe space and so just
to know that you're a part of that
unfortunately
sometimes trauma and hard times and
you know bad experiences and pain
are essential
for a certain lesson to take place and
i'm grateful for all of the trauma that
i experienced i can say it's smiling now
you know it sucked back then but
wow what a woman i am today because of
it and so you also will become the woman
of your dreams by pushing through and
understanding that you're an important
part to this whole thing and
um all the mothers who have ever birthed
are truly with you it's not just a
saying for
spirituality or for to be cute like they
really are and that's part of the magic
of birth you get to feel that with that
intensity of the child emerging like
wow every woman on earth can do this and
you know those who chose to do this did
this and i'm here because of this you
get to have all of that in that moment
it's just you get to be in awe and just
know you're going to have that
experience no matter what happens that
all moment it's super special and um
yeah we're all so special and a part of
this big unfolding and i'm so excited
for our daughters and our sons also
including everybody i love that
i love the way you said that because
it's so true we are all part of this
collective
and the experience of birth and i think
it's so empowering and helpful to just
realize and to be told from other women
too that like you are a goddess you can
do this i know it sounds a little bit
cheesy maybe but it is really helpful
like you can influence your birth and
it's empowering to know that like your
story matters and
it's all beautiful and it's all it's all
impactful to the greater story yeah and
all the choices that we make about birth
is just as fine tuning you know for our
future generations you know so the way
that you choose to birth it's like
you know that's just you fine-tuning for
your for your legacy how you choose to
birth whether you go in the hospital
whether you're at home whether you do it
freely in the ocean with dolphins you
know that's also important um
because we're all unlearning we all have
certain spaces and we grow up
differently like we all have we all live
similar but very different lives you
know
so that's important to consider as well
oh i so agree i think you should
everyone should give birth where they
feel the safest whether that's at a
hospital or at a home or a birth center
wherever you feel the safest is where
you should give birth and you don't need
to compare or look at other women and
judge yourself if you're not doing it
the way that someone else is doing it if
that's where you feel safest like tap in
tune into your heart and just
go where you need to be you know and
that and that's everyone's story is
going to be different and that's all
beautiful too
and that sets you up to be able to
welcome stories that aren't going to
plan right because when you just
are there anything can happen right it's
just like animals do like giraffes like
they're gonna birth where they're gonna
birth you know they're gonna make sure
that they feel safe but they're gonna
give birth you know
um
that's important to consider as well
because the stories get flip flopped and
all up and down and you just gotta be
present to just give birth like in the
car even you know all um and all mothers
who give birth in the car like rushing
to wherever they're supposed to give
birth right and the baby's like nope now
there's so many funny aspects to birth
and birth stories and i really
appreciate you sharing all this and
sharing your story your stories
basically
we got a little little bit of all of
them
and i just appreciate you being here and
i feel like it was so much fun to have
this conversation and like we could go
on and on but it's
yeah thank you so much for sharing it's
such a vulnerable thing to share and i'm
really happy for you you guys she just
gave her seven weeks ago that's
crazy fourth baby amazing
i'm truly outnumbered and and truly
grateful that you've invited me into the
space i feel so held to just share my
story it's always very healing you know
very close to giving birth to just talk
about the birth and so totally thank you
for sharing this special moment and
hello to all of the people that you that
you touch as well i'm so happy to just
be a part of this like i'm just i'm so
grateful
thank you so where can people find you
after listening to this
yeah so i am on instagram solely right
now i was on youtube but channel got
deleted and so just being present with
that change you know um so i'm on
instagram as phoenix wild
and um i i spell it differently so p h e
o n i x dot wild and yeah that's where i
am
perfect a lot of amazing things in the
works so definitely love to connect with
everybody what do you have in the works
what's going on
yeah so i have um a homeschool course
just starting homeschooling i want to
just support families a lot of people
who are homeschooling out of the blue
and want to just do it naturally and
simply and so i'm creating a course to
support that that's great
and yeah i'm really excited about just
sharing my journey about homeschooling
and to just provide an additional
resource out there for people who are
attracted to the way that we homeschool
and so that will be coming out very soon
and
yeah a couple of other things
a book
um we're working on some organic
baby products um just a resource a
marketplace for people to just go get
high quality baby products i also get a
lot of questions i'm sure you do about
what to put on your baby like what do
you use what's you know what's organic
really mean when you know amongst all of
these other brands who are lying to us
you know we've all been
i won't name any brands but the ones
that are green aren't always green
so true
we're also creating a marketplace for
that for mothers um to be able to tap
into that so a lot of amazing things
happening
perfect well go follow her at
phoenix.wild and i will put the link
below in the show notes and the
description boxes if you're watching on
youtube so you can just keep up to date
with what's going on with her and what
she has coming in store so thank you so
much jordan i really appreciate it
thank you so much ellen it's been an
honor thank you so much of course okay
bye everyone
you